wir wollten dass ihr wissen in der bild
live redaktion wie steht es eigentlich
um unseren corona schutz monatelang nach
der zweite impfung wir haben das testen
lassen gestern in einem großen bild
testzentrum bei uns im haus haben
vorgehabt 50 unserer bild reporter dort
auf antikörper testen zu lassen das
ergebnis wir haben 150 unserer
bild-reporter kollegen testen lassen
freiwillig in unserem großen bild
testzentrum und patricia platil hat
jetzt das ergebnis also wie geht sind
unsere bild-reporter kollegen noch gegen
korona geschützt wie viel antikörper
haben die noch im blut
vielen dank und das sehen wir hier an
dieser zunächst mal ein bisschen schwer
zu überblickenden karte also jedes
kleine kreuze in ist ein bild
mitarbeiter und das ist das ergebnis des
antikörpertest ich habe mehr
unterstützung geholt um auch nicht hier
in diese komplizierte karte zu bringen
es ist unser leben und wissen redaktion
ist feinstes den großen antikörpertest
gestern begleitet und natürlich habe
auch medizinische unterstützung
professor karsten wessel ist uns auch
jetzt zugeschaltet hilft uns ein
bisschen bei der einordnung denn
professor es ist ja nicht ganz klar ab
wann an welchem wert man sich ganz genau
ostern sollte oder nicht da gibt es so
ein paar grauzone gibt es so eine art
wie so eine art ampel system erklären
sie uns bitte gerne mal zunächst was
genau ist ein antikörpertest was sagt er
überhaupt aus also die antikörper sind
wichtig um uns zum einen vor der
infektion zu schützen und dann auch
schwere verläufe zu verhindern deshalb
eine abwehrwaffe des immunsystems gegen
das virus und diese antikörper werden
halt durch die impfung erzeugt und die
kann ich messen und träge dann einen
wert der sich mittlerweile halt in bau
pro milliliter ausdrückt und damit wird
er dann auch vergleichbar zwischen
verschiedenen tests und man kann
sicherlich sagen je mehr antikörper ich
habe desto besser bin ich auch geschützt
das problem was wir aktuell haben ist
dass wir noch keinen wirklichen
grenzwert kennen ab welchem wert man
wirklich welchen schutz hat von daher
kann man nur sagen wenn man ganz ganz
wenig hat ist es wahrscheinlich eine
aussage und wenn man ganz ganz viel hat
ist es auch eine aussage es gibt halt
wie gesagt ich schon gesagt habe ihn
relativ großen graubereich noch in der
zwischenzeit zone und dann müssen wir in
der wissenschaft natürlich noch ein
bisschen mehr forschen das haben wir uns
jetzt mal dieses diagramm hat er
gemeinsam genauer an jeder bild
mitarbeiter ist ein kreuzchen jeder der
dort unten gestern in der schlange stand
in antikörpertest man muss dazu sagen
das ist ein kleiner pieks in den finger
professor reagieren sie mich wenn ich
irgendwas falsch erklärt wird das blut
abgenommen es dauert circa 15 minuten
und dann hat man das ergebnis dann hat
man diese zahl hatte was genau können
wir jetzt hier sehen hier oben sehen wir
grün grün heißt immer alles ist tipptop
ii und rot weiß man immer oh gott das
kann schwierig werden ja so ähnlich also
man weiß ja dass über 1000 sagt man dass
der schutz noch relativ gut ist obwohl
er herr professor schon gesagt hat das
ist alles ein bisschen vage ist es gibt
den großen graubereich aber alles unter
21 da kann man davon ausgehen dass der
schutz vielleicht nicht mehr so hoch ist
und die verteilung ist halt wirklich
wenn sich das ja ganz ganz wild da ist
ja alles dabei also von ganz unten unter
20 weiß niemand aber hier in diesem
bereich waren schon auch ein paar leute
gerade so knapp über 20 das war zum
beispiel eine person die gerade die
erste impfung hinter sich hatte und hat
mir gesehen da ist der schutz noch kaum
vorhanden oder baut sich gerade erst auf
und dann hier oben da waren die leute
schon echt begeistert und bei den 3000er
werten wer erreicht denn also jetzt ohne
die namen in der ganzen kollegen wenn
sie wollen aber wie kommt man da wollen
wir hin das sind ja quasi die
superhelden wie können in den winter
gehen und können schon fast von sich
behaupten corona kann mir nichts anhaben
ja ist laut professor wasser sagt jetzt
irgendwie das gegenteil aber im prinzip
ist es schon so dass man also ist es
natürlich jetzt nicht repräsentativ was
wir gemacht haben 150 leute das ist
jetzt keine keine
valide studie aber man hat schon gesehen
hat die leute die hier bei den oberen
werten waren das waren zum größten teil
sind ja nur 4 aber es waren personen
geimpft und genesen waren und auch eine
person die einfach doppelt geimpft war
es könnte natürlich sein dass eine
infektion überstanden wurde ohne dass
man es gemerkt hat dass kann man es
leider nicht sagen mit diesem test
konnte man leider nicht sehen gab es
eine infektion oder ist das nur die
impfung der hat einfach nur den wert
ausgespuckt diese maschine und wir
anhand dessen hat sich hatte diese wilde
wilde konstellation ergeben professor
wachse dann erreicht man denn überhaupt
hier diese 3000 also diesen wert und man
sagt meine güte mir kann in diesem
winter nicht viel passieren musste eine
corona infektion das passt schon
zwangsweise vorausgegangen seien aber
kommt man in diesem bereich auch schon
doppelt geimpft oder vielleicht gar nur
mit booster also die höhe der antikörper
hängt zum einen natürlich immer von der
person ab wie gut ich reagiere zum
anderen natürlich auch immer von dem
impfstoff und ganz wichtig wie lange die
im funktionär ist das heißt kurze zeit
nach der zweiten impfung hat man auch
schon leute gehabt die wahrscheinlich so
hohe antikörper spiegel hatten die gehen
halt über die zeit wieder verloren und
die personen die jetzt bei ihnen auf
dieser grafik ganz oben liegen das waren
halt überwiegend leute die sowohl die
infektion durchgemacht haben als auch
schon zweimal geimpft waren das heißt
sie sind mehr oder weniger schon gebucht
hat das was wir jetzt gerade machen
wollen bei den leuten die erst zweimal
geimpft sind und dass schon ein halbes
jahr her ist wenn man dann halt noch mal
ein drittes mal im dann kommt man auch
wieder da oben in diese ganz hohen
bereiche wir sehen ja die meisten der
mitarbeiter die sich gestern haben
testen lassen die bewegen sich so in
diesem feld es ist so um die 1000 er
marke ein bisschen drüber manche bewegen
sich bei 2.000 was sind das für kollegen
auch hier wenn wir keine namen aber
welche geschichte haben die ungefähr ich
nehme mal an das ist so ein bisschen wie
bei mir also mann wurde irgendwann im
sommer gehen hat zwei impfungen bekommen
und jetzt irgendwann im winter würde
dann der booster anstehen ja also es ist
ganz ganz unterschiedliches kann man gar
nicht so pauschal sagen also die meisten
aus dem team wohnt tatsächlich im sommer
geimpft waren hatten ihre letzte impfung
vielleicht im juni juli und da sind aber
ganz unterschiedliche fälle dabei auch
leute die mit astrazeneca geimpft wurden
infektion hinter sich hatten
personen die das kann man gar nicht so
pauschal sagen
da ist eigentlich alles mögliche dabei
also im unteren bereich aber das hat er
glaube ich habe auch was aber zu gestern
schon gesagt und das hat sich irgendwie
ein bisschen bestätigt dass die personen
die diese einmal impfung hatten mit
johnson johnson sich tatsächlich eher so
ein unteren bereich
befinden das hatten sie auch so
angekündigt dass die erfahrungswerte
dazu sagen und da tat sich gestern so
ein bisschen bestätigt könnte man sagen
lassen sie uns mal was der wechsel über
diesen unteren bereich besonders
sprechen denn das sind ja die menschen
die sich jetzt im prinzip relativ stelle
meine booster impfung kümmern müssen
richtig das ist richtig also wenn ganz
wenige antikörper vorliegen kann man
sagen dass der schutz vor der eine
infektion wahrscheinlich sehr schwach
ist wie hoch dann der schutz vor einem
schweren verlauf ist es ist im moment
noch sehr fraglich das heißt dass da
kann man keine seriöse aussage zu machen
aber es gibt dann ganz klar die
empfehlung solche leute sollten sich um
ein booster termin bemühen man muss auch
noch mal ganz klar sagen es ist nicht
gefährlich wenn man sich trotz hoher
antikörper noch eine booster impfung ab
holt also da gibt es keine negativen
effekte es kann halt nur sein dass wenn
man 3000 bau pro milliliter antikörper
hat und sich dann nochmal postert dass
die booster impfung mehr oder weniger
umsonst war aber sie ist zumindest nicht
gefährlich und von daher muss man jetzt
nicht zwangsläufig immer vorher so einen
antikörpertest machen und wir sehen ja
auch bei diesen tests dass wenn man
zweimal geimpft ist und die zweite
impfung wirklich schon ein halbes jahr
oder länger her ist dann sind die
meisten leute in diesem mittleren oder
teilweise auch unteren bereich und um
nochmal auf die johnson johnson
geimpften gekommen zu kommen die sind
halt meistens nur einmal geimpft und da
sieht man schon dass da die antikörper
spiegel über die zeit deutlich
nachlassen und deshalb hier auch eine
ganz klare impfempfehlungen ist ja auch
schon von der stiko entsprechend
empfohlen worden diese leute sollten
sich auch um eine zweite impfung bemühen
und dann muss man nicht erst ein halbes
jahr warten das kann man auch schon bis
zu vier wochen nach dieser ersten
johnson johnson im funk machen wie ist
denn ihre empfehlung abschließend sam
für all die menschen die hier im
mittelfeld liegen also die eigentlich
wenn sie es jetzt noch gar nicht haben
testen lassen wahrscheinlich anzunehmen
irgendwo im mittelfeld mit ihren
antikörpern liegen sollte sich jeder
langsam jetzt schon auch wenn man zwei
impfungen erhalten haben um ein booster
termin kümmern oder zumindest zu einem
antikörper
also man kann ein bisschen kritisieren
und das zuerst betrifft das sicherlich
die älteren also alle die über 60 sind
wenn deren zweite impfung schon mehr als
sechs monate her ist macht es absolut
sinn sich um eine booster impfung zu
bemühen und dann muss man nicht vorher
die antike bei bestimmen weil wir wissen
dass bei diesen leuten die antike
spiegel bei den allermeisten schon in
einem bereich sind wo sie deutlich von
einem booster profitieren würden das
heißt da ganz klare empfehlung sich um
einen termin zu bemühen bei den jüngeren
also unter 60 wenn keine vorerkrankungen
vorliegen und der die zweite impfung
jetzt noch keine sechs monate her ist
hat man sicherlich auch noch zeit wir
sehen natürlich aktuell dass die
incidents zahlen nach oben gehen und
eine booster impfung für alle davon
profitiert dann natürlich eine 30
jährige die sich jetzt buchen lassen
würde weil ihre impfung zwei mal sechs
monate her ist die hat dann natürlich
einen besseren selbstschutz aber was
dann noch viel viel wichtiger ist der
fremdschutz also das weitergeben des
virus das wird durch diesen booster auch
noch mal deutlich verstärkt und das ist
ja auch die hoffnung dass wenn wir
möglichst viele leute jetzt boostern
dass wir damit auch die vierte welle
sehr gut eindämmen können und von daher
gibt es natürlich die empfehlung auch
für die jüngeren auch wenn jetzt die
antikörper so um die 1000 sind wenn die
zweite impfung sechs monate her ist doch
sich zu überlegen ob man sich postern
lassen kann wobei für den selbstschutz
natürlich so die notwendigkeit nicht
unbedingt da ist aber sicherlich für
diesen fremdschutz das hat professor
karsten wessel vielen herzlichen dank
für die medizinische einschätzung
unseres großen antikörper test den wir
gestern hier im foyer des einzel
springer hauses durchgeführt haben 50
kollegen eingeladen 150 sind gekommen du
weißt auch mitarbeiter weiß aus unserer
redaktion leben und wissen vielen dank
auch für einen besuch im studio